Comic Con episode 4 fans hope is a film
that we may we shot two years ago here
at comic-con and we wanted to one of the
film to kind of give you a window into
the world that you kind of really never
seen we've heard about comic-con usually
only get the story of like you know
famous people are freaks in costumes
that's all they do and I thought there
was a real deeper story to tell about
the passion the drive why people come
here what is why is it so important okay
we're good like to be able to be a comic
con with this film showing it in
ballroom 20 was probably gonna be like
4,000 people there tonight I mean it's
going to be raucous and exciting i can't
i'm i am giddy about showing it tonight
Holly Conrad our costume designer will
be there tonight and skip hint to skip
Harvey one of our comic book artists who
was trying to break in will be there
Anthony Calder on our toy collector yeah
we'll be there you know Eric Henson our
comic book artist has now done three or
four covers you know with a couple
different book publishers I mean it's
amazing that guy's the career is really
taking off really wanted to I want to do
this so badly well I came I'd always
wanted to come and never could you know
for whatever reasons life you know
always has always gets in the way for
something and in 2009 I got called to do
the simpsons 20th anniversary special
for fox and the minute I hung up the
phone I was like we're going to
comic-con I was like we're going to
comic-con we're going to go there we're
gonna find Simpson superfans we're gonna
we're going to go there and have people
kind of wax rhapsodic about all things
homer and why they love this you know
the show and when we were here shooting
that special I was like there's a deeper
story to tell about comic-con there's
something great we could do and I met
Stanley that night and stands like we
should make a movie together we we
should make a we should make a
documentary about comic-con I was like
that's a great idea mr. Lee yes we
should and it was a geek dream team that
came together to make this film in now
and now it's on DVD and that geek dream
team is available in action figure form
probably the first time ever a
documentary has action figures I have to
think this is probably a first usually
when we make a film we start our first
pass are at the assembly edit is about
five hours and then it goes down to
about
three and a half and then it goes down
to about three and then two and a half
and once you start hitting about two and
a half two hours is when it gets really
hard because that stuff that it's really
good like there's like gold at those
points that you're like we ought to lose
the gold as much as that seems great it
doesn't benefit the movie and and it's
tough you know you have a lot of fights
with your co-producers and your editors
and people leave angry but you know we
you know that it's it all comes it's all
part of the process it's all part of the
battle that is making a movie